now
obviously most people know you from your
dip set ties i want to kind of go back
before that kind of give me your history
of how you got into music man like we're
like like
at what year did you start taking this
[ __ ] serious obviously there was
there there was a jail writer before you
started working with dipset yeah hell
yeah i was 11 when i first started
um i was influenced by like wu-tang
snoop dogg
um tupac big big pun big al
right right you know what i mean but
yeah i started rapping as a at 11
12 13. you know running the streets
battling
getting my making a name for myself and
then somebody at 16 somebody entered
introduced me to killer and hauling one
day so yeah
and then history from there so from 16
on you was just
cam locked in with you from 16 and all
yeah it's a fact
damn showing me the ropes you know i was
just like i was like a sponge around
jewels around kim around gym
just you know picking up little things
from everything
business at what point in time so
obviously 16 years old you meet cam
how long how long after that was it
before you actually
you know were officially well it took me
a minute because
i had to prove myself you know and we
was like we from harlem so we always
competitive
so cam used to touch me like i was wild
young and
it don't matter where it was at i'll
take the train there i'll walk there it
didn't matter i was that hungry so
you know he'll make sure i was on my
toes so
anytime i come around he'll be like yo
let me hear something
it could be a room full of people just
we could be at a bar right here
something
and if it sound like something i spit
alright now i heard that let me hear
something
else are you falling off oh i know you
ain't slacking
right so i never i never wanted that
reaction from anybody so i always stayed
on my toes and
i always proved myself like they didn't
have to come to me
like i hear is a video shoot i'll pull
up to the video shoot with my mixtape
done
right yo look i'm done here i'm ready
i'm ready to go i just need you to host
it i'm gonna put it out
what year what year was uh okay i don't
know how old you are but when you're 16
are you first 35
so when you when you're 16 you first
meet cam
this is around what the which era
is this this is actually this is after
yeah this is around the time
i met him uh right when juelz got signed
jim didn't even have a deal yet was this
around take me home
no come home come home take me home i'm
tripping that's like a drake song
yeah bro you could just i just had this
this huge drake argument
all day today on the internet and i was
just listening to drake's album in my
car
uh he's all right that's what the
argument was about
um but no come home with me um
i feel like was like cam's like coming
out party uh
you know his first project with
rockefeller
and i feel like that kicked off the real
like obviously dipset was doing their
thing with the mixtapes but i feel like
that really kicked off the wave of like
the movement where if it was felt
nationwide like
oh yeah like dipset was something that
wasn't just like new york secret you
know what i'm saying
no that's a fact i don't know if cam
planned it
or i really think it probably happened
naturally but he has that confidence
like
all of us from harlem has that
confidence where it's like
this is this what we gonna do b we're
gonna put out this we're gonna
we was like the first dip set honestly
was like the first
rap group to put out street mixtapes
without djs like a dj
because usually you could debate you
could debate g-unit
you could debate because they we came
out yeah but they still had like
when you say without a dj like obviously
they had who kid and
i think who kid was was the dj was
hosting their team
no but k slay helped host it i was i was
gonna say casey hosted the dipset [ __ ]
yeah